je construis un vaisseau spatial tu
penses vraiment tu vas pouvoir voler oil
pas toi tu es c'est impossible car les
seuls ceux qui essayent peuvent
accomplir l'impossible si on pdi-p
bonjour visible
[Musique]
c'est normal que tu sois très déçu car
c'est vrai ça nous arrive à tous d'avoir
besoin d'un peu deg
on accueille jouer ensemble c'est une
[Musique]
je peux te raconter une histoire
on a tous un dock on peut partager
quelques fois il faut seulement y
regarder de plus près pour le voir
j'adore tes histoires
à vos marques prêts
[Musique]
croix donne un tegra
mais on rouge puis dans l'espace
ouais je sais pas comment tu as fait car
[Musique]